ce soir pour performance gersois
philippe katerine pour son cd louxor
j'adore extrait de son album robots
avant tout catherine sera à l'olympia le
30 octobre a dit catherine bonsoir
bonsoir bonsoir pochette déjà très
parlant de dire très années 70 sinon au
70 c
sébastien aussi c'est aussi du christ et
ouais ouais ouais ça ça me fait penser
que vous avez eu une vocation de prêtre
jusqu'à l'âge de 12 ans mais je m'en
suis remis mais je vous rassure mais
quand vous avez perdu la foi si je puis
dire est ce que vous savez exactement le
moment où vous avez décidé ne plus être
prête
je me suis rendu compte
ce qui se passe à l'église n'était pas
exactement ce qui se passerait à
l'extérieur quand les gens parlent
sortaient de l'église c'est pas de ce
qu'ils avaient entendu ce qui mettait
pas en pratique et moi non plus je ne
m'étais pas en pratique ce que j'avais
entendu à l'église
alors revenons à ce single donc extrait
donald l'avait fait avec une groupe boxe
tout seul dans votre carrière qu'est ce
que c'est que le groupe boxe boxe et une
petite machine avec lequel tu tu peut
programmer des rillettes frd
des notes avec des c'est quelque chose
d'assez sophistiqué c'est rudimentaire
en même temps qu après les choses aux
finances
d'accord alors les thèmes de cet album
est ce que c'est les thèmes récurrents
de philippe katerine ça vous êtes
obsédés à quelques obsessions on peut le
dire quand même les chiffres la
numérologie par exemple doit beaucoup à
paraître oui et non ah oui a
complètement la scatologie aussi à brens
j'adore tout ce qui est alors jusqu à nu
c'est tout ça alors est-ce que vous
abondez toujours votre caca tech qui est
une espèce de collection des troncs
privé que vous avez ça continue si je
puis dire bien sûr reçu une position
toujours en mouvement en perpétuelle
métamorphose est toujours régénérer
absolument oui et aussi des conduites
des obsessions plus grave chez les dames
on vous avait été opérée à coeur ouvert
vous dites que ça quand vous aviez huit
ans et que ça a tout changé
oui ça a dû changer des choses par
rapport à mon narcissisme
c'est à dire que je vais j'ai dû
j'ai dû devenir un art 6 après cette
opération
mais mon avis mais est-ce que c'est
aussi ce n'est pas l'idée aussi de
sentir un survivant et donc à mon avis
c'est l'asse narcisse oui à cette comble
telle qu elle être considérée comme un
miracle après de la science
donc ça à la fois une bonne heure et une
tragédie alors quand je vois ce mirage
il comprend un peu mieux ce serait quand
même encore il ya encore une fonction
non pas christique nous quelques désirs
est ce que philippe katerine souhaite
est un saint geours et comment ils se le
trait est adoré à sa annonce à jamais
non je vais à n'ont jamais eu alors un
martyr à hamar tir j'ai vu souvent c'est
cette petite faiblesse petite tentation
voyagé j'ai eu mais je le dis au passé à
moi j'essaie de me guérir un peu alors
on a une petite fascination pour les
talons aiguilles c'est moi ça pour te
dit a produit agents partent mais
légèrement récupérer être femme cette
femme en tant qu'homme on est femme est
dans tout quand on accepte enfin comme
femme
on est enfin home
je peux
dire ça mais
c'est pas une gestion ben oui c'est
juste une
un moyen pour
on va axer un autre
un autre état est ce que vous êtes de
ceux qui disent qu'il écrit avec sa
partie féminine
la victime lui féminine qui l'ennuie pas
forcément oui forcément
oui on va dire je n'arrive pas à séparer
la partie féminine de notre art et
masculine
c'est impossible et de quelle influence
vous revendiquez aux influences je sais
pas du tout je sais pas
deux sens des choses que je déteste et
que surfer rosa 2
obispo
c'était chansons qui me
emilie a vraiment pourquoi parce que le
les jeux de mots
elle a rien demandé là rien demandé la
large bande et là me paraît
un cynisme
et sam apprend autant qu'eux
ce que j'adore on en arrive et on a
presque du mal à imaginer que philippe
qu'athènes puisse être choqué par une
chanson
ben moi je serai sans ça ça me choque
ah ouais ouais la part d'aidé
des territoires qui
je peux plus je peux plus de plus je
suis parfait ça il reste quelques
blessures quand même un jeu philippe
katerine bien entendu sinon c'est mon
art très belles sinon on est mort après
les blessures c'est la marque alors on
va faire quelque chose de vivant
on va vous écouter qu'est-ce que vous
avez choisi de lui chanter ce soir a
capella oui les chansons a capella il
s'appelle patati patata l'industrie
mature et bien nous écoutons philippe
katerine et patati et patata et les
quatrièmes c'est à vous et patati et
patata défunt j'en ai ras-le-bol de moi
et patati et patata ras-le-bol râle badr
al badr album j'en ai marre de mon nez
j'en ai marre de mes mains j'en ai marre
de mes couilles film et si partout où je
vais monter mais ma mes coutumes me suis
pas tout je vais par ci par là par la
partie par ci par là par la partie j'en
ai marre de mes oreilles de mes pieds de
mon ami de mon ventre et de mes poils
ils me suivent partout où je devais dans
la rue dans le métro dans mon
appartement tout le temps partout bappoo
tout le temps tout le temps partout
partout tout le temps ras-le-bol
ras-le-bol ras-le-bol ras-le-bol
j'en ai marre de ma bouche vingt années
pour ce qu bonne ni pour koné patati et
patata bonne année bonne santé patati et
patata qu'on ai marre de me souvenir de
me souvenir de mes souvenirs j'en ai
marre de mes ancêtres qui parle à ma
place à des débats des tables du
bâtiment et à petits pas ne pas
tu ne t'entends pas à l'eau chérie tu es
toujours là
j'ai besoin de toi quand je suis comme
ça va le petit à petit à petit notre
avatar a battu van hout a battu bolton
rattrape par rapport à nos camarades
magath
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]